[Music]
bad times at the El Royale still lead to
one mystery a man said at the film's
close who was on the highly coveted tape
that Dalian decided to burn during her
and pretend priest Daniel Flint's escape
throughout the movie
there are several clues dropped as to
who the featured person's identity is
and I believe that I have the answer the
tape is first mentioned when the FBI
agent played by Jon Hamm discovers
hidden microphones and a camera behind
the two-way mirror overlooking the rooms
the agent is there recovering
microphones after a surveillance
operation so we can draw the conclusion
that whoever they were spying on was a
VIP the agents supervisor also tells him
that retrieving the microphones of the
utmost importance and therefore we can
guess that should they be discovered it
would have disastrous consequences for
the FBI Father Flynn later discovers the
tape hidden in miles his room and
instantly recognizes the man on it he
attempts to take it along with the money
and when Billy Lee and the rest of his
Co look at the film they summarized that
it's worth more than both lots of money
combined it is hinted that the man on
the tape is dead which is another huge
clue to it being ex-president John F
Kennedy evidence to support this comes
when miles is confined and he confesses
that he saw a senator something which
Kennedy was before his presidency being
of a prostitute the time setting of 1969
makes it plausible as Kennedy had been
assassinated by this point and behind
the reception we can see a photograph of
Marilyn Monroe who is rumored to be
having an affair with JFK the El Royale
itself is based on the real-life hotel
at Cal and never which was on the border
of California and Nevada this was a
hotel at the Kennedys frequented
regularly during the 60s in 2001 the
hotel was reopened and an employee
giving it to her stated that Marilyn
Monroe stayed there
guidon with JFK in a circular bed whilst
bad times at the El Royale never
out-and-out states he was on the tape
Timmy it's crystal clear
perhaps they avoided naming the person
on it due to the potential lawsuits that
could bring brother that there's little
clues that hint towards the identity of
the man in question so what are your
thoughts on who is on the tape comment
below and let me know and if you enjoyed
this video check out my ending explained
on the movie linked at the end of this
one this is a channel for people who are
mad about movies so if that's the kind
of thing you like hit subscribe thanks
again for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you
[Music]